bienvenue aux internationaux de squash
on les finales des internationaux squash
de la réunion donc à l'année 2014
donc c'est la deuxième fois qu'on
organise cette manifestation et on
invite des joueurs entre des très bons
joueurs et joueuses donc de partout dans
le monde et notre invité vitesse vedette
cette année c'était thierry lincou
himself donc il nous a fait le plaisir
de devenir partager avec nous en ce
moment donc il n'y a pas eu seulement
participer et partager la compétition
mais il a également participé à des
actions envers les jeunes envers les
écoles de squash envers les différents
clubs donc c'était
moment très agréable pour donner du
spectacle il faut être en forme parce
que il faut être solide sur les jambes
il faut être créatif donc c'est pas
c'est pas si facile que ça en fait je
veux pas de laisser aller dans laisser
aller complètement espérer voilà à faire
du choc avec des raquettes ça n'existe
pas effectivement un des grands projets
donc dans normalement qui devait se
réaliser cette année c'était d'organiser
le jubilé de thierry lincou quoi pour
des problèmes de logistique de matériel
donc on l'a décalé sur l'année prochaine
et pour ça on souhaite acquérir un court
de squash vitré on souhaite le
réutiliser dans notre participation donc
en tant que sport de démonstration pour
les jeux des îles
et ensuite ce cours sera utilisé pour le
dans le futur pôle espoir grâce au
département n'a pu au niveau de la ligue
embauché quatre emplois à venir
donc on l'informé en tant qu animateur
sportif
donc c'est eux qui interviennent sur les
actions d'initiation de découverte avec
les squasheurs une aide au niveau
fonctionnement on a également une aide
donc au niveau dure la manifestation
donc ça nous ça nous permet de réaliser
plusieurs actions envers les jeunes
envers tout le public parce que est un
des objectifs de la ligue donc si le
positionner le squash en tant que sport
pour tous c'est de le positionner aussi
longtemps que ce coin du sport sans toi